was a full podcast welcome to the
Western full podcast with Felipe Esparza
Rodrigo Torres we got Johnny rocky he's
back people and we have Lisa Esparza
here Emma over there on the Wheels of
Steel checking in doing all the
engineering work of ten people all by
herself
what's up shout out to her the unspoken
heroes of all things comedy studio
Network here where we do our show here
instead of a building with an RV inside
wanna go camping that's like Evernote if
they haven't a Walgreens and there's a
chuck-e-cheese inside
we're asking why we're having a cookie
cheese inside well there's a pizza hut
across the street
it's like Joker's comedy club yeah
Joker's comedy club a rich men yeah
Richland watch Richland Washington they
have a casino they have a arcade Chuck
fake chocolate cheese Chuckie Cinelli
and a bowling alley and stand-up comedy
and right after the comedy show dancing
warehouse they're coming more than old
Kmart would have been perfect spot right
there's tons of cameras look at the IKEA
that's empty over there in Burbank you
know they need that place but now in a
ghetto-ass mall that we went to by our
hotel and you went to the more ghetto
one right there was no stores yeah they
have an unemployment off any security
officer over there oh then the same day
we went over there and at night is where
we see that big lady sleeping in the
donut shop yes she was asleep unless you
were reading at this got a book right
there too on her passage
she'll really nom I think it was Chaucer
phille yes Canterbury Tales be
I swear the age of Calero
what's up man shoutout to everybody that
came out to the arlington giraffe house
in DC we had an awesome time a lot of
people showed up shut up - Brian Cardona
who that guy I met my first time I met
him I went to the DC improv and that was
there and kicked it and it's been
hanging out ever since so what's up to
him we got there on the night before M
to my surprise we had no press in this
day which was cool because I let you
sleep in sometimes so me another we go
we went to the Lincoln Memorial like at
11:30 at night yeah and it was like a
lot of people just hanging out and our
live driver told us that it's legal to
smoke in DC and most people smoke right
so by the Lincoln Memorial so we got
there man people just puffing bro like
we were in the 60s Pro protesting the
Vietnam War and just walking around man
and it was cool man was dark we saw a
bunch of people with the razor scooters
and look cool but nice huh it was real
cool and then we walk to the Washington
Monument and the White House and the
White House yeah that's where we started
7900 87 steps
it's so funny because it's still
marijuana still federally illegal I mean
are there federal police there who could
bust you yeah they were the nicest
federal federal but they were all super
nice super nice chill chill not all like
ready to grab the gun after walking with
everything so there it was I have yeah
freer like that in a long time yeah was
the Secret Service police
metropox Raleigh's was generalized and
then a bunch of parts of police and we
were in DC that someone on one of the
nights someone got through the shootout
then I got there the night we got there
there was a shooter in the Columbia
Columbia Heights Wow which is by way
like gang shootout or like what first it
was a mass person a mass shooter and
then it came out to be a an ar-15 coming
out of a vehicle shooting at people
so purpose intended for somebody so now
we're gonna 15 four tries yeah and it
wasn't it was a nice night man but we
walked a lot and then we found a step I
wonder went to the first 7-eleven
without a 7-eleven sign it was on our
map but it didn't have nothing in the
front it was just like if you're walking
by a big building with like you know the
little 7-eleven printed on the door and
stickers but not layout but no big old
oh yeah they don't want to pay the feed
new shoes walking in there dog yeah man
and we were starving by the way but one
of them that we would you gotta find
good food at 7-eleven that's sad
yes as a meat eater do you eat the stuff
from 7-eleven that they make they're
like that's what the little tuxedos that
they have now they look like old total
yeah I do you would probably break a
tooth trying to bite into that [ __ ] or
some other one I've rolled up all this
stuff that's back on that grill that
needed area yeah I like to keep those
the hotdogs
I said I'm am/pm we stopped mopping up
nasty iamp about what I would like put
two burgers a little bag you ever
exterminate those places yeah yeah we
did that with that one on the corner
right there on Fletcher has roaches dude
what next two rigs across the Derrick's
I mean all those put all those places
right there I'm gonna name names they
all have roaches home and they all have
roaches I thought lizard in one of them
and I told the dude and he just shrugged
commercial
it real quick do you want to tell them
about our driver oh man live drivers
they were all wack bro I took the first
one man but that was their where and no
DC where the old lady man like like
Toby's grandma rose auntie dog and if
she got lost she missed she missed the
exit the same exit twice in a row and
every loose ball she looks like she
needed glasses you have that yeah she
and then she told us don't worry I'm
raised in DC I know you know little cans
of incense the little cans with a little
too warm she have four of them opener in
her car Jeff four of them open by the
way that's what boy he saw what are
these little signs for and then she
takes off the other way in the map is
toner go this way and then she's up and
then she was okay and then she said that
uh-oh so many cones cones follow the
clothes right she would go left cuz the
cones were distracting her and then the
and then the construction on the highway
was distracting her where she pulled off
twice on the exit and then another one
she just went all the way around went
back and then we got back on the same
for you we were at 35 miles an hour and
just hit it at 40 oh man please a little
casino buzz killers right
I had a old lady driving me from the
place in Devon just not that far away
from our house like ten minutes away and
taking me back home because Philippe had
the car for something and she I got in
there and she was mad at her GPS and she
was like bang banging on her phone like
that's gonna like it's a TV set or
something
the Fonz with the jukebox there she's
banging on her phone this stupid thing
I'm just gonna wing it
no only a bleep man and she was like oh
which way and I said just go straight
just straight down here and you just
turned I'd give her the simplest
directions even though it took a little
longer than the freeway I didn't care
she was like oh forget it I'm just old
lady I even suggested the old lady on my
Franco Drive she wearing a coat like she
just came back from church like she
don't like mama from that movie I'm
Ladykillers my pickles they don't they
don't screen them we're like okay all
right your car's adequate then they
review that or 12 hours old but but she
looks like she needs glasses and she's
not gonna wear glasses that's what she
was they know me without glasses glasses
make you look ugly I think you're
mid-60s you have to take a neutral
she'll 860 no no she was pushing six but
it yeah but they don't like early 60 if
you're not like that age you don't have
to take a retest and so you could get
away with not wearing glasses for a
while even though you start to need more
and more you know better and better
glasses or a higher prescription or
whatever her deal is so they don't check
you again I never see there's no way to
check for that like I'd go with pops and
he goes into the free world about the
same speed but then he he put a gas but
oh it's a bottle little angel foot
but I would like Magnus speed up I was
like come on man and then uh on the
other night we had a driver you know
like I knew this driver gonna come out
on the wrong side of the street so I'm
gonna give him the benefit of the doubt
and walk to the corner okay I'll just
catch him in the corner he'll just make
a left you don't make him that I make a
u-turn cannot be all right so I knew in
there we were to find us so he makes a
u-turn to catch us
Midway we're walking so he stops where
we're walking like nobody's trying to
stop there but they start complaining oh
yes they did wait oh that didn't make
this u-turn in Virginia right here
they'll give you tickets for getting
picked up on the side of the road it's
like dude you made the illegal u-turn no
we're not driving no he's worried about
picking up another side of the road
they're making those two illegal u-turns
they're not gonna bust us dude you're
the one that's driving down there are
always bad drivers oh my god three stars
with attitude
I'm back as I said that San Diego I went
to a home fries by the bay November 2nd
November 2nd tickets on sale now
how about yeah put your soda back there
dude he was forcing me to put my soda on
the side holder of the door and it's
like dude all right it doesn't fit and
then it's not the sodas to the side now
it's gonna drip on your little carpet
dude it's like what do you want it was
like dude it was like Stalin driving huh
yeah man was a totalitarian those guys
get way too [ __ ] mad who's on the zoo
in like psy - come on bro enough dude
you're not driving a limo whenever I got
shows up with wearing a suit to drive a
lift I know they'll be a problem UNITA
Wade I used to wear the same suit from
the Emmys yeah I don't get a person I
don't pick up people don't dress up for
the for the fall apart like that so just
say that we're gonna start at 8:00 sorry
have five that's none of the Emmys you
know we're tux bro the whole night
driving a [ __ ] Hyundai and it was a
baseball game just you know wear a hat
bro ease up the game to this day if the
Trump rally bros in a where our mega hat
you know he'll he'll blend in
whatever is there dude and be like
lately late that counts yeah you can't
get extra tip money what no I had a lift
driver one time this was like probably
one of the last times I had a lift
driver by myself and I don't think I'm
gonna do it anymore man because it grows
like he was wearing shorts first of all
like who is this old white dude named
drifty I love Pete Rose like oh yeah
like old batboy the old basketball
shorts not this not that one's the fools
were this group not the knee the
kneeling seven looking a rule the girl
his legs are all wide open I'm behind
like behind the passenger seat in the
back seat and I just see him like he's
you know doing the man spread his legs
are all wide while he's driving and he's
leaning he's leaning like half way over
this way driving driving like this like
this guy is creepy any his shorts
reminded me of some dude at a barbecue
one time when I was young and he had his
legs open and those shorts on he did
have any underwear and it was it was
gross and I saw his penis and surprised
not saying they were good man coach
shorts never mess I'm sorry Medicare how
good-looking you are surprised Clayton
surprised nuts that he's never good my
mom never complains dog she didn't say
nothing she walked up talk to the
manager they saw some huh yeah no she
told on that I'm just pull it out fat
gross dog oh yeah you look like you
weighed 400 pounds that was like Joey
Diaz at this biggest you know I'm saying
here's the nut sack [ __ ]
I was about to shown the Cuban Negron
they kicked me out yeah man I remember
like when a birthday party Christine
like fat morano's bro like full wearing
their like golf shorts cover yourself
they like the one ball the balling
creepy now like a like a like a sore
thumb bro Oh like sad
it's like saying hello my baby hello
you tell us that one part that they
never wash so it's all like lizard skin
now let's all [ __ ] like a raisin yeah
nutsack attack but that's gross oh but
nobody you just cover up dude damn yeah
but I don't know how the players were
played back in the deal with little
white shorts bro I probably had a
jockstrap in another set I mean you know
brothers how to probably tire back
what's our food this Friday I'm gonna be
in El Paso Texas year with with real
Torres who was it coming
oh I'd be there Johnny well he'll be
there I guess and Toby Hicks
Oh Toby Toby hey Swami okay yeah all
right dog try a vegan try vegan taco dog
I don't need before algebra so people
don't eat before they do they're sent
into the same sense but it's like is my
I was talking with Johnny I'm just like
dude just try it
eat one it's not gonna kill you yeah
braise off over here trying to feed me
food ESCO so he's treating li you like
your mama but that's one foot like
Toby's what those fools are probably
like I can go on without eating [ __ ] I
can't do I get headaches like well I
won't if I do though check me out over
this week is gonna come out but I'm
gonna be on par 106 with Nick Cannon
I'm gonna be on a cruise show in the
morning I'm gonna be on the Big Boy's
neighborhood next week I'm gonna do
Kevin and bean before came in before
being
EBEs
but I wasn't giving him other Nick
Cannon show and we talked after the show
and I started talking about comedy
because that fool Toria San Diego
he knows San Diego nahi New Moon doggies
I was throw in the rooms bro like people
say I started somewhere and I know that
like they're like at the de-aged would
they be doing comedy at least 20 years
and I asked for tests on bro which start
at yeah you know the rooms and you
started off right don't know but you
know who was there at the time
man and if a newcomer comes in yeah I
remember hanging out with Johnny and ly
[ __ ] you were texted bro crying
you would shake it so who said that he
said that he told me that um Toby that
uh his mom II to date that do doc they
used to run the back to his room yeah he
goes yeah man
my mom was dating Nam doc and totally go
yeah
so Toby the only yeah Toby haste yeah
man he got locked up then got out go
down supposed to be my sitcom I said
what I'm coming promoter had a friend
who had a roommate I'm not even against
a roommate who was locked out who comes
out really so Toby Higgs was part of
though his character some ideas they
come idea and Doc based on his life
level when he first started brownie with
a look that before all that before all
that we don't know he had a pitch ready
you know yeah maybe his early game bro
like [ __ ] he had like somebody helping
them you know like this was it'll be my
pitch amazing huh yeah give him ready
well think about it bro and I hit up
Toby hey oh that's true tell em I said
why's that
relative so Nick mechanic was there when
he went to prison and came for the
credit cards probably a child probably
like 13 15 to 16 years old a chip oh
geez but he would have different route
oh now what's table food to everybody
who's watching us live more more Rico
Jesse Francisco
Jesse again Moses Frank Avila sorry the
doctor Diaz Omar Gonzalez Gustavo and
everybody air
Freeman LTG to Iran
fine Toma six one nine people he rocked
903 Christopher England sorry you missed
her so at the end of Valley but you know
I broke will be back dog
don't get scared hateful that word
people Don you know that Hyundai had a
call a car called Heber on right yeah
but you know how [ __ ] yeah well how
how ghetto people check like Latinos are
trying to be all like up idiot
oh yeah right here with mighty broad
yeah dick that's the people at all there
wasn't no listen l sketch about like
that and it was like every time they
would say Coronado like everything would
speak with just an American accent the
[ __ ] so you can't believe my
dad now my Mexican then um Sons of
Anarchy right yeah and becoming it you
know we're funny way over the stripper
car joe says the officers right with the
name of his strip bar in [ __ ] sons of
anarchy
I'm Jimmy Smith mmm will call diosa and
this will do sorry no pass oh yeah man
you know we would turn that one time huh
well had that big-ass coke rock and they
wanted a party the was the old staff of
the comic strip bar yeah we pulled out
and then we went to the house after and
you had that big-ass Rock it was
probably the way Jodie look at it twice
it gets bigger for that yeah Texas maybe
Texas the strippers the real good BYOB
yeah you bring an ice chest for a cure
now by [ __ ] yeah it was crazy but women
suffer there man
we can make some money buying drinks you
control whether somebody gets too drunk
know what you look for over there at
that [ __ ] bandido and you settle down
you'll get stomped out right you get
stopped out they know to come correct
even though even the aging people and
the Middle Eastern people they were they
were like all righty don't [ __ ] up the
cash flow that was there in that place
ain't around anymore no I will stop
Prince Machiavelli those prints matching
Bally's a guy will come in like at noon
or at midnight and bring burritos yeah
you like I'm sorry I could give you a
lap down with a burrito lady was so real
I guess here bro Joseph Lucero thank you
thank you no relation to my niece
Michelle who's that over little boy oh
hi are you from LA
no actually I'm from San Diego so it's
kind of nice to hear you talk about a
Nick you know I mean sighs I've been
keepin over keep an eye on him for years
man yeah yeah we don't know which we are
canon I don't know each other personally
yeah well person I went that other way
I've been locked up my whole lives what
person you go southeast and
we had a guy there were not sure who
from the otai neighborhood okay I'm
right next to him I was born in Logan
Heights area I grew up on Golden Hills
they moved all the way around where the
Frog grew up loads yeah ya know I was
out there and Oklahoma for a long time
so you're over there Logan like Chicano
Park
she kind of parked my whole family's
from Logan Heights then I got bream was
they were from Sherman I'm all the
Brotherhood some Meccano
69 Street so it was spread out man we
were apostles putting their work
so now you started you grew up in San
Diego and why don't you uh you win it
you got locked up did some time yes sir
yes sir I grew up in San Diego man but I
really grew up in the system
I was born in San Diego my mother is
blond hair blue eyes my possum stuck up
there cuz my dream would of and it's
crazy because um you know when the 70s
from what I understood my pops still
sold heroin and my mom's that's how they
connected you know I mean and they fell
in love and had me and then they split
apart you know but back then I was like
why did you marry a white woman in you
know I tell my mom why'd you go for a
Mexican
I mean my pops on me straight out she
was like hey nobody pulling white lady
over with dope in the car cuz that dope
in the car yeah so I mean so I mean it
could be a little surfer girl hey that's
the way I looked at it for me I mean all
walks life is beautiful but I've always
loved love Dinah's man yeah man here we
go man they get corrected with Jaguars
bro oh the club yeah there's men around
anymore no no yeah pillars that have
like Greek pillars in front of remember
bro you never part with what Portuguese
no I was now and that was another one
that's not around so they closed with
some they were too good military were
there yeah for bliss Roy I'll try to
find funny stories in a passel you know
like because you always find funny
stories where ever you go
and um and and I saw a right there man
dies at Red Parrot Street Bar ain't no
Paso how the [ __ ] that he died and I
went over there bro you like sick 79
years old died getting a lap dance oh
wow like like the third girl realized
after she checked his wallet that he was
dead wrong yeah he died in a strip bar I
figured I was fatigued about I can't
without you about that I [ __ ] sad no
he's stiffened up it's just
who's this stiff alright so many what
what movie was that was that color
though
when what's-his-name glass shiny was
like if I'm gonna go I want to go like
that those colors what's colors how my
hind out one hand and my width in the
other yeah you already gained beg you
when I squeak mo you were locked up in
something that why I was going away that
I was arrested uh I was arrested at an
iron man was the first time I was
arrested and man I I didn't stop you
know when you did I know
I stole weed from my mom's pantry but
then he's all the cast of lomas they
needed they needed a youngster to climb
through a window so I burglarized the
house not knowing I was burglarized in
the house your house no not my health Oh
another I don't even know who that was
but I climbed through the window and
they open up the garage and I ended up
getting one of those little [ __ ] ATC
oh you had to be rich to have that yeah
three wheeler yes oh I thought it was
the [ __ ] until I was riding down the
street and the cops pulled me over and
I'm not I don't know what the [ __ ] I
didn't know I stole it oh yeah I mean
that's so stupid it sounds but I ended
up going to juvenile hall 2801 metal
hard drive man at nine years old I
didn't like you like oh man well she
never let me go to my parents but you
know if you go to my house my house was
a shooting gallery
you know no one stepped up like why
people do it manually mess up his life
so they don't hands on the cop
independence when they're pulling over
it all true that true that my family was
well known in that that small area so
they knew yeah exactly I was they knew
exactly would have taken there like
we're not gonna take him back and
actually I didn't want him to take me
back because then it would have been my
fault if they ready yeah right and then
no Smythe you already smart all that way
yeah cuz this is your appearance
you don't want you to be locked up you
know saying cuz n you by yourself you
get into you know [ __ ] foster homes
and [ __ ] you blow up a whole nother feel
good even though my mom's are strung out
that was my mama could nobody tell me no
different you spoke bad about her that
was my love of my life you know what I
mean like she was there strung out she
was I came first well second to the
drugs but you know addiction is one
thing and you know you grow up with that
emptiness like I found it on the streets
you were nine years old how long locked
up for are just a couple of days they
released me you know and there but it
was back to back to back was it like in
there at 9:00 at night I was scared I
was crying like a little [ __ ] a lot of
older kids by seventeen sixteen oh [ __ ]
yeah man walked in there
younger than you there's kids I was
there was probably two or three kids I
don't really remember I'm 42 now yeah so
back then also man if your house will
raid it if your house was raided and
they rusted everybody the kid wanted you
in automatically yes they some day I
went to a place called Patrick Harris it
was a hill but no there was a I went to
Hillcrest for a day and none of my tias
nobody wanted me man
nobody wanted my mom was the black sheep
I'm a Latino side they hated my mom
cause she was wetter you know I mean but
then again my well I used to say don't
[ __ ] speak to him in Spanish because
when he gets older he'll have a better
chance of getting a [ __ ] job well
that backfired on me you know you know
so that's all I know
me right but you know life is life is I
mean I'm blessed to go to the [ __ ] that
I went through because the world man now
Felipe as far as the podcast so what's a
full podcast yes sir so um you were
locked up at nine and you got hooked on
heroin no no no no no no that was that
was my parents that I hated heroin go
hated heroin I became another penicillin
yeah that ready actually I took
penicillin for like 15 years I was hit
by a car two times crushed at one ran
over my stomach must be my second time
like I hit the tour my head was ripped
off just by yeah was you know maybe my
mom wasn't watching me when I ran across
the [ __ ] street at 4:00 but you
know hey there's one of those things you
get older you know you told you know I'm
saying no no no nobody said watch my kid
yeah the streets were cool like they'd
be alive because growing up as a kid I'm
like you like you left a little boy who
survived bro like when people wander in
[ __ ] what happened to Joseph why we were
just talking about whatever happened to
him you know he's a liar there's this
little boy oh boy oh boy oh no there's a
little boy that I grew up with in
Section eight housing in Colorado and
his name is Harley his mom was a biker
chick and she had two kids but this kid
was the youngest he was like a year
walked around in cowboy boots and a
diaper and that's it his name was hardly
and his mom's name was Barbara and I
wouldn't know what happened this kid cuz
he just walked around
the apartment complex in the courtyard
and everything nobody he never went home
until I guess at night she'd come to
look for the kids but she was messed up
on stuff we're not a little boy was that
a little little time yes brother you
know who they were with the mom was
partying all the time and every once in
a while he's my mother's please we'll
watch out for you but you know there's
so much the streets could do bro you
know it's probably a morning there's a
lot perverts out there so um there was a
little boy you know he ended up drowning
in a pool
oh wow his mom was partying and
everybody was partying bro and a grown
woman ended up drowning to everybody
with a party it should learn when you're
looking in the hood bro like it's just
crazy dawg yeah especially in a bad
neighborhood oh yeah this almost drugs
and for me it was cool I mean [ __ ] I
still I still I was I had two dreams I
wanted to [ __ ] work at the San Diego
Zoo play professional football San Diego
Zoo cuz know I know animals told me I
was stupid they're [ __ ] they never
showed me nothin but love I could push
the dog away and it would come back so I
was known through the hood on escape
with all their comes they caught me dirt
rocks I was dirty little [ __ ]
they didn't wash me right you know Hey
Juke right so the homies called me dirt
rock and I was young
ICQ just be on the skateboard pulled by
the dogs my favorite dog's name was bear
and I [ __ ] used to go to jail
more than me because he never had his
cat a gongs my mom always had to go to
the [ __ ] anime the town to pick him up
but he was like he was my best friend he
had one [ __ ] nut he was part Chow part
[ __ ] a German Shepherd and all the
homies big ol boss yeah all the homies
from Lomas you still had pit bulls of
[ __ ] so they would clown me when I
rolled up [ __ ] that Chow right there
and be like my child [ __ ] that dog and
one day my shell got into it with a pit
bull and [ __ ] him up gonna kill your
dog and I'm crying no nobody kill my
daughter is going on get up out of it
real quick
yeah child's can be aggressive too that
was that was probably a purple tongue
yeah purple I love that purple tone with
[ __ ] spots on it those it was like my
own little [ __ ] pokedollars [ __ ]
when you get into like movies and all
that rapping or whoever I did Joey want
to be a movies always wanted to be in
movies man when I was a kid man that was
my escape you know I mean I could get
lost in TV you know I mean cuz in the
home and the house it was [ __ ] bro I
mean it was the home right but it was
still [ __ ] you don't I mean like
nobody why don't want to be I didn't
want to be there I wanted to be like
Ricky shoulder huh me I wanted to you
know mean Silver Spoons [ __ ] back to
my leg that was that was one of strokes
different strokes brother hell yeah
millionaire the rich people back then
Blair bro good times I never saw her or
all in the family I never saw like
lower-class poor people like I want to
go bike riding with Blair from backs
effects of life hey rich people
everything is possible you you said you
were locked up most your life so what
when did you when did that first happen
or was it a long sentence or a bunch of
different like you know it was a bunch
of different sentences I just man I
found myself in the gang and just acting
out and I found just that that that
camerado you know that I thought I
wasn't getting at home and I [ __ ] I
tried to be all I could be I wanted to
be that man here and I'm saying that
Brotherhood yes
and it was it was a different night that
work belief system just took me over and
I was willing to do the rest of my life
for it man I was really man sad to think
about it now but it's made me who I am
today and I'm very grateful for that
you know name but man it was a lot of
pain a lot of hurt a lot of [ __ ]
abandonment just I wish I didn't go
through yeah but I respect what it is
you know I'm saying like cuz it's put me
on the path now that isolation that you
had to grow up in - yeah and then like
[ __ ] man I got PTSD they say you know
I'm like yeah I know I have PTSD I never
fought for this crunchy that's
disrespect to the you know Armed Forces
for you to tell me that I think every
person who grew up in the hood seeing
the violence that you saw and and you
guys experienced at a young age I think
all you guys have PTSD in different
forms and it takes it it manifests
itself in alcoholism and drug addiction
and abuse at home you know it's it's not
I mean it's the same sort of situation
but they
you don't get any treatment you never
got any therapy [ __ ] get away
it's from kissing other people can get
from drinking from other people too and
you get somebody oral sex you can give
them an STD that if you have oral sex
with somebody and you have an outbreak
or they have an outbreak and they're
giving you oral sex you can get anybody
yeah that's also what you said yeah this
is um I mean before they would before
they told me I was oh you have to be a
drug addict for all the hurt all the
crimes that are committed oh you must be
a drug that's always you say so they
always want to put you through substance
abuse [ __ ] became a substance abuse
counselor while I was a gang member huh
me cuz I went through all the [ __ ]
programs and a precise locked up so he's
just educated me on the [ __ ] but I
didn't use dope I smoked weed and
[ __ ] drink that was a bad alcoholic
but function you know you go KOF
oh I've tried cocaine crystal slam here
wonderful alright alcohol alcohol isn't
one that I felt I've just still to this
day if I impose anything you sober no
yes me too late a mile twenty-fifth I'll
do the interview look like I only come
no man I don't crave crack heroin in
those drugs unless I have a beer yeah if
I have one beer I need some coke I'm not
one I'm like
I'm a participant you will go through
this like I always talk about this but
um you see when you know you're gonna
you've been on and off the wagon right
but yes so this is the last is the first
time I've been sober feels long cuz I
remember man like the day I fell off the
wagon everything was lined up perfect
for me yeah [ __ ] yeah because I make
before I drag I knew it that guy already
had dope oh yeah then I did something
like I told somebody I wasn't gonna come
home alright I just let my right leave
I'm just staying here bro
I'm staying man I am positive how cool
it alright I'm gonna grab a beer make
friend with that guy and then imma make
friends wherever that guy came from and
I'm gonna stay wherever that guy came
from that was how it happened man I
ended up drinking and I go party with
that guy only has one bump they attained
to the stuff where he got it and then I
stay at the other place so they kicked
me out or jumped me yeah cuz you're
paying for it right yeah but then after
a while do you become a resident there
then the [ __ ] Sun comes up and you're
like that's down the feet get cold like
what's [ __ ] going on now then you
remember being up for five days bro yeah
by the sixth day bro you don't know
what's going on you don't know you don't
know time no more that's had to been in
the nine years old yeah man normal mm oh
[ __ ]
yeah my remember like like if I would
leave I would leave a bottle here and
then an hour later I come back and it's
not there and I think it's an hour later
butts been a day good one bro I think
that's how he is though he was he's
always a binge user yeah he wasn't a
chronic user like he'd people he had
home jokey points but yeah it was binge
you'd been for like three months at a
time and then he sober up for a while
now it's funny you say that because
that's what my doctor told me and he was
like what you're doing is you work out
[ __ ] Monday through Friday and then
Friday through [ __ ] Monday I'm
getting smashed like beyond - and then
I'm shocking the [ __ ] out of my heart he
was like you're better off drinking
every [ __ ] day then [ __ ] binge
drinking because you're gonna blow your
heart up
thought I was doing grams like me - I
thought I did lose I don't do it every
day yeah yeah exactly on me but you do
enough in that short amount of time
[ __ ] yeah about life I was doing bad
with knowledge
I knew I was doing bad when the person
who does it every day of his life and
little normal they call me an enabler
yeah bro you show up right here bro you
[ __ ] my host [ __ ] cuz you make it
party harder than he usually goes I just
party every day and do my paintings and
then Salim and Burhan Panhandle but when
you're here you just want to go hardcore
fullest yeah borrow bikes I'm a touch of
the big in rap I was tired
dude last night I was talking to my mom
we had the wrap party for the Mayans
emcee second season and on the way home
I was telling my mom something
everything from gang banging to [ __ ]
drinking to even sobriety to not being
an actor you want to be the [ __ ] best
because he threw himself in a hundred
percent
well yeah cuz I'm a [ __ ] failure most
the time if I don't you know I
self-sabotage big-time and that can't
happen this time because I got three
kids three beautiful okay and a family
depends on me that I'm trying to be a
better man and I still [ __ ] that up one
day at a time you know what I mean but
I'll say beautiful thing man like right
now the old lady's [ __ ] pissed at me
but you know a intermarry and it's mom
no I'm not married but it's the mother
of my kids you don't understand whom I
still love to death but you know it is
what it is you're carrying my son just
graduated college Joseph Raymond Lucero
21 but the communications degree my 10
year old daughter Brooklyn and my four
year old daughter Evelyn same woman a
life yeah same woman same awesome room
I'm scattered I'm lucky I'm lucky yeah
this is life [ __ ] I'm lucky they're
not scattered he's my son
that's your brother you know where that
your brother come on oh shut up Marty
mother Brooke killed him last week no
San Diego man so you grew up with in the
90s I was born in 77 so I grew up in 80s
and the 90s but I was locked up most of
the 90s man for what criminal stuff yeah
a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] not be Mexican they
just locked me out that pay taxes yeah
no it was that gang life I mean I was I
wanted to be the best you know I hated I
hated getting locked up but in order to
be the best you know everybody said well
I never got caught why I always [ __ ]
cop yeah and I'm an athletic
[ __ ] I just never ran I was like
[ __ ] you know I mean like stupid [ __ ]
but you know from California throwed it
in prison I've been home almost 17 years
now I came home April 8 2003
I'll started working for homeboy
industries with father Greg Boyle and
ever since then man is trying to give
back man trying to put somewhere just
started well what jobs you started
homeboy bakery nah he walked father
great walk me straight in became the
office manager right down 19 1960 News
first-rate yeah it was it was dope it
was dope father Greg helped him before
homeboy existed but that's when I found
that's what I found we met her years ago
and that's when I found her in in the
office I think it was in um it was in
like 2003 so that was a Vietnamese guy
work in the front hall yeah [ __ ] the
other fool no not Hong [ __ ] luck and
what was the the what this from me yeah
yes little Gus Wow
I grew up my dementia school with art
with with um with Gus's older brothers
and older
okay Manny and all those guys I'm sorry
Dukes because he stole a Dukes you know
when Gus was in it
he studied Dukes before like the I was
saying like the the kids who are 50 now
or eighteen fifty or they're hitting 47
years old they're not kids no more but
those guys were [ __ ] athletic bro
yeah like they were play I don't know if
your neighbor was like that but these
camera play football in other
neighborhoods and they don't have to do
it after they stopped playing sports
they just shot each other right
but they were play baseball gives each
other football games each other whatever
sport it was and East LA Dukes man I
remember man who kind were drinking or
no elementary dog like they were playing
football they were playing I'm junior
high school and they were a drinking
like there's photos of those guys on
Facebook and they're there with baseball
bats and like a case of beer of
Budweiser and they're like not even none
of them are 17 years old that's crazy
they had a mustache and [ __ ] yeah bro
some other guy named Andy Yama's that's
my agent can answer this you're broke
whatever speaker yeah we are apart for
you with Kevin Hart as well get here now
audition I want you to play this thing
man sid haig guy you know just like him
our Peter said hey oh yeah that the
embodiment of work I want where you've
been around forever we're just talking
about a comma
cuz we just sell we're promoting you a
yeah we had a job for you you're gonna
play a Sid Hague's
story you know you know city the guy
within the movie The Hills Have Eyes
other Rob Zombie movies oh yes no rest
in peace said yes yeah definitely socha
Theresa I think that the embodiment of
work I want so a career like that man
where he's been around what he's been
over a hundred thirty five movies
he's eight years old but every every
every John rabe remembers him from
somewhere yeah like I remember him from
that movie I remember him from that
movie though the do he this guy's did
movies bro
that that wouldn't that um you can even
play now people get offended like yeah
we called the big bird cage in Egypt for
real / it is what it is big bird cage
and in every cage nothing but women with
big boobs and nice bodies bro
half naked there and he was like like a
general bro camera to save them and have
sex with all about axiom you Armenian
bro by the way shoutout to Armenia from
Fresno Emilio Rivera just did a just
finished was it free from hell it is I'm
looking forward to watching those that
was dope it's just you know sad is last
movie and I mean recipes to him and much
love to his family definitely so yeah
but your agents they both we are over
Felipe - man that would be beautiful
pill down I'm a mechanic bro that gets
killed at the end boy like I asked for
the money for the motorcycles and I take
me out to the desert naked it kill me
[ __ ] that bro you you you'd be a Mayan
but what happy we need we need we know
how we don't know cars bro yeah that's
my baby right here bro you got no
[ __ ] power porn seriously [ __ ]
because I know there's there's I
remember Mike de Stefano the late mighty
Stefano he there was a guy in Florida
then he needed a motorcycle and then I
got in a wheelchair right but he wanted
to ride a motorcycle and he knew a guy
that was dying in New York who hadn't
worn a harley-davidson that was built
for a [ __ ] wheelchair so somehow
Micah thing hooked him up and it was it
was a wheelchair like it just it was a
motorcycle but it was a wheelchair and
you can wear them up on the freeway like
it like a normal car right now
listen somebody's gonna [ __ ] do that
now custom it's what I knew where was
were you a Mayan went on sons of anarchy
no ma'am no joined it during there's a
if you were on sons every so it's it's
in the present eight years later career
and so like if you died in sons like you
cannot be a part of Mayans oh so this is
a master yes so this is post the prequel
would be the first nine or the phone
however that would be about like Opie's
dad wait wait so this mine did mine show
right now it's eight years later eight
years at post Jack's death whoa man no
wonder stop watching any I came in there
thinking that it was like that's all
before before everything yeah so I would
it was a me look to hear on older yeah
yeah yeah well you know this way yes sir
that's why yeah that's why I mean you're
in this he's not Marcus Alvarez he
became my Padrino okay so he became he
became the big dollar book okay man King
well you clarify that brother I'm no I
know I'm gonna go in and watch it again
yes miss dokgo this season is is
un-fuckin'-believable all our writers
are Latin eggs some sort of pain they
have come from and it's unheard of I
mean every not [ __ ] Casper behind it
behind behind the camera or camera grips
knighting Latino go that's beautiful and
I walked on to a few sets in my life and
not just the hood said but you know the
sets with lights camera action and
there's not too many Latinos and they're
all they see me and I come in as the
cholo riding no I'm a [ __ ] tank top
I'm not blasted and it's always like
they put their heads down and I'm I'm
polite as hell I'm very hospitable you
know I mean and so I can feel that like
their energy when they're nervous so
I'll make them how you doing I'm a make
them smile and then you know you leave
them what that tastes like
I'm not what you see on TV like I'm the
news I used to be but now this is why
I'm Aaron I'm saying that's so it's a
beautiful thing
yes bring your own motorcycle they
provided they provide our motorcycle
yeah you know how to ride
I do not abide what yes we learn on the
show yeah I did I knew how to ride my
it's crazy when I came over prison my
son taught me how to ride a quad in the
desert that was the first time I'd ever
by ATC ATC and then I I had a keyboard
mystery well there no it's crazy right
he was six dude yeah I'm saying yeah
that's the way his mother's family it
was the woman I family yeah yeah they
put us through a Glendale hardly gave us
a class was a weekend class well check
this hour I'm away on a Sunday morning
I'm driving through [ __ ] Glendale and
who does pulled me over because [ __ ]
yeah so he man he pulls me out of the
car and I'm soon as he comes up I'm like
as soon as you around my name we're
gonna get 664 187 look I've been home
from prison this long I'm not that guy
I [ __ ] tell him all this he comes
back back up gun drawn get out of the
[ __ ] car and I'm like dude I'm going
right there it's less than a block away
I'm on a motorcycle class if I miss this
[ __ ] I'm went there in the CHP is not
gonna let me finish the class the last
day so our cast his name's Rocco Vargas
he plays Gilley right when he's in the
next CEO is the next Army Ranger
so he's got juice with these cops and
they all [ __ ] love him so I called
him before I they the cops made it to my
door when they pulled me over and I was
like able get your ass over here because
I'm gonna I know you not just don't let
you go I was like dog get over God you
don't know how they treat me sure enough
as that cops pulling me out by gunpoint
he's running over and the guy looks at
him bro and he was like Rocco Vargas
like I was like dog and he was like that
guy's with me he's on their minds he was
like oh he's telling the truth he's like
yeah we gotta go around this and the
dude looks at him he was like I'll
[ __ ] let him go with nothing if you go
if you take a picture with me over there
I was the I was [ __ ] hurt I was like
California man I was like oh yeah he was
gonna [ __ ] me and [ __ ] and I lost my
that would have been like one more thing
in front of that would have self
sabotage on accident but before because
of my past it was a sad and that's not
to all law enforcement but for that
individual was kind of shady yeah help
with your television I walked into a man
walked into Mexico and Kim it and what
came out of it Mexico night tune showing
no ID
welcome to America was like what's up
tomato that officers watching cars now
in Ensenada no eyes
what's up food I'm gonna move with you
been in uh one movie actually to I'm
sorry I did grow although through my
head 365 story in the game then yeah
well I started I got the I got the break
with Gridiron Gang man it was on
accident with the rock that's a football
movie huh yeah and I walked in I was I
took about eight guys from from homeboys
they came in with casseon ball when I
took him into the sepal these dudes are
real gangsters you know I'm saying I
couldn't leave them up there [ __ ] camp
Kilpatrick cuz they would [ __ ] Jack
somebody right yeah
so I stayed on said well because I was
in shape and all blasted well after
three weeks of doing background with
these guys they pull me to the side and
they were like do you know what
continuity is and I was like nah and I
was like no I don't and uh Dwayne
Johnson was like basically you stand out
the most and we have to cut you or we
have to introduce you to the audience so
I was like what so we'll tell you that's
why I'm never in feels bro came back
Monday I was hell I was Chavez the
heavily tattooed kid and I went from
bathroom I went from fifty dollars a day
to five thousand dollars that was
unbelievable when they put my foot
that's when I was like I have to I can't
fail
yeah and Duane I would say this that
[ __ ] a real humble awesome man
I spent our first handshake my whole
back is blasted we're standing in line
and he tasked him in he says can I check
it back on I turn around his [ __ ]
Duane and I was like if you shake my
hand and the look in his eye was out of
respect and we shook hands and ever
since then it was it was a it was just
beautiful cuz you know you already gotta
be like that oh yeah [ __ ] you fool you
were a Chicano
I'm sorry you and I'm worried Chicano no
I was not I read for it but I wasn't in
our Chicano no the other guy who look
like
oh yeah what they did they definitely
did that therefore less I said yeah
definitely we were shooting minds at the
time yeah and you know what they won't
let me go to [ __ ] Canada bro
I'm a two-striker yeah I've tried to get
like big jobs I've had to lose because
of that there are a lot of homeboy
people who can't that's what father Greg
sitting here was on the show home with a
weird a guy here named fight baby
maybe in Dimona yeah my boy yeah he grew
up in my I grew up in his neighborhood
[ __ ] yeah the project so that guy who
told her that father Greg took him in
Lalo homeys and only if only for the
gray got in yeah they know how to stay
in New York ya know and it's true and
it's [ __ ] up too especially when
you're changing lives I mean you can't
even get in there with a DUI bro if you
have two DUIs yeah yeah or no and I have
because well Chris Brown I told him and
it's seven trailer for solo shows here a
trailer full of merch greater Purcell
Detroit right that's crazy
she really love television shows I've
been in a few television shows like the
first television shows jor-el Courtney
Cox you were sitting on Miami I was I
got cast but I didn't do the CSM no no
find that guy boy that was got a er
cold-case Criminal Minds shameless did
SWAT now mayans MC swat you were there
with juice yeah yeah yeah yeah juice hey
kid I guess I'm too whorey
Jimmy get some dude can I get our / -
but swab was dope
hopefully they'll bite me back into -
this season Magic Mike didn't bother was
the writer oh you know the show swap but
uh man if I can get back in that they
want to make me a confidential informant
though I'm saying [ __ ] do it man I do
whatever it takes the Rose you won't
take I won't take it up to a scene right
were there any window where he just took
it up the ass
yeah nah I mean you know
talking about it oh yeah it'll be like
this you know we could do it but then
that stunt doubles gotta go in there get
ready no no not that part but like but
just say that there's a sexual innuendo
where no playing no no no I do it all I
would do it all I'm down ain't nobody
saying he was looking at that well no
there's not a scene that I won't do that
I won't embrace man I made that
commitment that I will I won't take it
all because I don't want to just be ten
songs dog I don't care [ __ ] yes let's go
my house is hairy as hell but hey I
don't know I looking a [ __ ] Tom let's
go a little like a little a bunch of
little spiders came out of my ass yeah
you hold the bow from coming out yeah
what's up fool that's why bride's hair
where you know what's going on
so oh man you're an actor how do you
prepare for a role I mean of course
you're gonna play someone like you but
not everyone is like you you know you
bring something to the road too right
yeah def had to learn modality you bring
in real life the [ __ ] that we went
through you know like um not for
instance the Mayans you know me like I'm
supposed to my my character is creeper
he's an ex-junkie so I'm usually at
about 195 right now I'm like 172 oh I
like almost 27 pounds for this role so
if they when they do tap into my
character I can be that dope fiend on
ten how that losing [ __ ] weight you
know I mean so and that was hard because
I'm not used to you know being there but
it's that dedication that you want and
being able to tap in with with my past
because of my sobriety now with you know
I'm an AAA and I'd do the steps I
embrace that giving back I'm able to tap
into that pain and then that [ __ ]
doesn't take me out to drink or say [ __ ]
it yeah because then I can decompress
with you know come I'd rather I call it
and I say hey this is what I'm going
through and I'm saying I got to get this
[ __ ] mental
you know status and then you know you go
back into just being Joey but to be able
to [ __ ] go there I want to go I want
to bring that vulnerability I don't want
to just be the [ __ ] controller that
shoots every month yeah rolling everyone
job treating the mother wearing light
blue [ __ ] like green bandanas and
I've never do it no more at that bro
they were too real Doug looking people
know they went to the troop they were
wack member last year there was a lot
there was a lot that we're still were
afraid you know not the wrong people
yeah when you're watching television bro
and you were like watching to the one
John Street and they're like wait a
minute man nobody in my neighborhood
worth like we'd been Dennis but they
also weren't more than people who came
from that background this is something
special that like homeboy has this
relationship with film industry you know
and so a lot of those people end up
either on the crew but because it's LA I
think there's a lot more of that
crossover but now there's like people
being consultants on shows who have come
from the same background or being actors
on the shows and even maybe an actor
consultants would be like you know it
wouldn't happen this way this isn't
authentic you know when you're on the
set sometimes I mean have you ever run
into no lines or situations in the
script there's you know there's numerous
situations because there's a lot of
things that the higher powers debris and
I don't speak about them but they're you
know in the system that that will come
down on you because we know from
Southern California that's the bottom
line so with all due respect to all
walks of life you try to stay away from
those certain things those certain
truths you want to be truthful but you
want to be truthful without
disrespecting any cause or or any type
of establishment if that makes sense
yeah yeah but like with homeboys like I
was the first one to get that gig you
know and then Pauline Richard kovrov was
a great [ __ ] friend of mine I took him
to central casting and got him his first
[ __ ] his headshots and next you know
this [ __ ] blows up yeah I met
with JP and Fabien because for Southland
because they wanted real authentic
paintings so we got Fabien the border to
to put a lot of the artwork for
Southlands murals and do the murals and
[ __ ] and then that show blew up richer
cabron and dude [ __ ] he took off he
embraced the art so good it was just
[ __ ] unbelievable I became an
alcoholic and [ __ ] regressed I got
shot four times yeah dad died of
pancreatic cancer cancer and I was just
on a self-pity [ __ ] you know I mean but
then I stopped drinking actually this I
stayed single them all 2015 but it was
actually the third was it was right
after the Pacquiao [ __ ] Mayweather
fight that was the last time I got drunk
me too late too late October to them
yeah
man whatever I have a I live in about
with homeboy industry like a since 2003
okay so that would let homeboy that I
like they worked over the years in
movies like one guy he passed away
already died he got killed Timothy
record he worked with that lady that was
the producer of the Forrest Gump movie
he never hurt her ass little assistant
and he was also him for his go and that
I'm another friend
it's one of my favorite movie they
caught him they call him green and he
from Clarence Street and that guy is
like he works on those cop shows on ABC
he's like a technical person all the
time
consultant yeah he's working all the
show that he makes sure that we do is
they make sure it looks actual yeah
that's dope
there's a dude there's another dude uh
Mike Beltran for me he's from East LA
but he's a he was a he was a la sheriff
he's on Mayans now he's they do that
he's dead what is he Bellator a referee
as well he's an awesome [ __ ]
he's a real dough from East LA area
there's a lot of guys that we got in the
Mayans Hector Verdugo who's from right
there what is it a hazard yeah as a
project so he's our he's one of the main
guys at homeboy industries we got him
into the Mayans Marcos's in the Mayans
there's a lot of brothers from homeboys
that our background in the mines bro a
[ __ ] fitted how how about that one
dude that he came or in a movie
Apocalypto me turn about a row yeah who
through he'll no no he didn't - oh well
actually I'm that guy will chase you
Rudy and like yeah but the main main guy
bro
the main guy that was like his song got
hit in the eye the main guy when I
Capilouto he played in the mine now yeah
I saw him I said whatever I know this
guy yeah raw was expiry he does dumb he
does a lot of dances too right yeah [ __ ]
yeah he's gonna be really old right yeah
[ __ ] he's the [ __ ]
oh he's a [ __ ] hi he's this [ __ ] inside
yeah no I'll let him know really he's a
we wrapped he actually went here ended
up going to he ended up going to right
now he's in Blyth no Palm Springs so
he's doing uh he's got a new movie with
a Jason Gamboa just a beautiful job
right now man that dude is working and
but the I cling to him
in a sense because of his spirituality
because that's where I'm at you don't
understand it I'm not in if you're gonna
say that negative [ __ ] bro like I can't
be around it you don't sound like I just
I shift myself you don't sound like it's
just it's not me like I can't let that
energy take me because I'm a [ __ ] I'm
self destruct yeah oh yeah big time
yeah I mean like I can't let that happen
to me like I'm a [ __ ] idiot you know
bottom line and I can't let that become
in the present you know what's up fool
so growing up man he loved the Warriors
are good yeah and I want them to [ __ ]
make the Warriors [ __ ] warrior a bolo
stop based on a lie people can always
think about how would it be for them to
get out the neighborhood when there's a
lift and all that first of all bro if
you if [ __ ] 50,000 gangbangers once
wants to go after one gang we'll find a
way
[ __ ] stop that game from moving I'm
[ __ ] block off the freeways
everything kind of fire the freeways
will make sure that foot does not make
it from Echo Park to the valley
especially with everything [ __ ] live
yeah I mean I mean not every badass bro
yeah y'all have you have [ __ ] Chuy
Gomez yeah San Francisco doing the radio
hey hey boppers we have we have a
friends here from Coney Island and I do
mean the Warriors a little song for them
nowhere to rub that woman the mesh and
then that movie the warrior she pretty
much giving you the play-by-play of
what's going down in the street so you
have Roxanne Shantay bro from Sirius
everybody were to go oh what's your
channel 43 serious on same one rocks
yeah I'm Sam the woman I want to be yo
man
you actually love that shows a
breakdance show show are serious dude I
saw her I was like oh I would have died
if I saw I saw that's how I would feel
about shot day if I was a see shot day
I'd be like oh my you ain't Keys Maddie
she's got a show it's like 1 2 3 or
something like that
Rock the Bells radio on XM and it's a
great show she is she's like she sticks
to her script in there you know her she
does a couple little sketches and stuff
and then she plays music but she
interview she's in LA right now
interviewing I'm gonna have to read up
my [ __ ] XM radio yes I just bought a
new client to give them a [ __ ] I was
like I was listening all that [ __ ] she
had built battling me on last night he's
making a comeback
yeah right and they were talking about
when you come to our lay it's not like
hanging out at Fresno or hanging out in
Florida you really got to look nice all
the time but you're gonna go out and
then she was telling people advice on
how to ladies you gotta clean your feet
Alina you can't have those shiny ass
corn man you gotta put some lotion mo we
have a corn on your toe looking like a
pearl put some makeup on that [ __ ] make
it cut that foot off what's up full
upcoming shows I'm coming to our
Passover Friday September 27th at this
week at the Plaza theater Corpus Christi
Texas
the following day September 28 Salina
auditorium in los angeles california
october 4th that's next Friday Microsoft
theater also Winterhaven California the
following day I'm coming to you my area
October 5th I check flights I check
everything looks like I'm driving there
I'm gonna be a catch on Casino Riverside
California Spanish show October 8th at
live art center with Rodrigo Torres and
if you had come down man they serve beer
and chips st. Paul Minnesota October
11th at the old way Center Sylmar
California October 15 that'll be a
Spanish show at casa
tory's this shows right here man at Casa
Torres are amazing we have a full-on
Spanish Oh amazing food the tortillas
are nothing to brag about
but I'm a brag about them because
they're good man you rebuttal you have
your mom make tortillas and then like
you got you get them and you gotta cook
it again and make it softer
these are those tortillas man they get
better once you cook them again mmm and
then the beans are good and they have a
lot most of their tacos are like karma
hard shell right yeah yeah at Casa
Torres
except for that I got the shrimp ones in
the worse off you and I went to go eat
up enchilada had lobster without right
below do you want to know where it is
you didn't announce San Antonio October
26 yes
October 26 at Obon Center okay Tolbert
said what are you talking about lobster
again
oh that's at Casa Vega in Valley
although she really mention it and
that's where Brad Pitt and they an art
ago when Sharon Tate and the others go
to coyote
yeah in what's Upon a Time in Hollywood
they go to Casa Vega and you get the
lobster quesadillas I don't need those
anymore but they were all right yeah
you're coming to San Diego - right yeah
I cuz I had last time I seen you was a
little [ __ ] venue in downtown probably
2013 I think it was though though though
Jimmy I mean um downtown comedy club
yeah there ya know I was happy to [ __ ] I
was happy to [ __ ] and see you brought
was like [ __ ] yet because it was the
first time I seen you I were like hell
yeah you're in San Diego that's when I
was my dad had just died I was like good
at that [ __ ] see there oh yeah but now
that you're gonna be at Humphrey's I
want to go to that push
what's your Instagram people get ahold
of you Joseph Raymond Lucero at
instagram.com yeah it's Joseph
underscore Raymond underscore Lucero
mine is hot man Maya that Shawn Mayans
and the show of snowfall my favorite
shows no rest imposed on John rest in
peace John man yeah no no I read to the
last oppose the last season by the way
which is pretty hot season that far I I
got cast in the first time we were also
in the first folks I was slow yeah also
first one but they recast it three times
the only one that stayed was Emily real
she was the only one that actually
[ __ ] made it through every single
cast when I see the Breaking Bad
yeah she and she was dope dude you know
I hope she pulls back into her little
breakdown but you know I wish her the
best you know who else the girl from
Breaking Bad now it's no fault what
happened no no the girls have grown the
young girl also is also girl yeah well
the truth wasn't Breaking Bad yeah she's
the girlfriend of Jesse oh she went to
my high school I know that chick
what's her name I have yes look Emily
Rios yeah I did a show with her I did
the closure was I was a I think she
hasn't no substance issue man she so she
felt love man but you know I say that
it's none of my business in that sense
but I give her I just I wish her the
best when they retire that's troubles
yeah one day at a time man you know
that's a Debbie you know well it's very
successful by the way she'd been
judicially game for a while she's done I
know that Breaking Bad when that her
first time because I know sure that
awful child actress yeah I said I didn't
know that yeah Keaton yeah boom we did
the closer but and um they thought I was
the one that killed the Raymond Raymond
on the closer's brother and there but
she played a [ __ ] dope ass partner
and that's we had we had connected you
know I mean she's I thought she was dope
dude and then she was booking [ __ ] left
or right but then I seen a lot of weight
gain and you know you just see the
difference in somebody and you know you
don't I mean cuz I've lived that life so
you know but you don't judge you just
wish you find that that peace within
yourself or somebody to help you
you know you see somebody make it from
where we come from and you want them to
[ __ ] make it but sometimes success is
so [ __ ] scary we self-sabotage but I
mean they told us for so long we ain't
gonna be [ __ ] we ain't [ __ ] oh yeah
so the back of our mind sometimes oh
[ __ ] yeah people like especially people
like you say you solve the structure
person and then like when you not only
but bad news you expect bad news oh yeah
I remember I remember like supposed to
be supposed to be happy for something
and then everybody's all happy for me
then I go behind a behind back page I go
no ever myself hey little bro everybody
say [ __ ] off I go to the back I do my
little crying bro so I won't have to go
use drugs because I was I want to feel
out the way they want to feel the way
they feel about me yeah about myself so
I feel like if I bust a little crack on
the side you know somebody somebody tell
me some shared enough your bet about
myself
well thank you for thank you for right
no dude I'm a [ __ ] all that do is cry
yeah man go I am seeing my daughters and
my kids in two weeks like an i FaceTime
I might cry cuz I [ __ ] miss them you
know I mean I'm just there and they're
in San Diego but we've been finished up
we just finished up the season and I'm
doing everything great you don't even
mean that I'm doing everything right but
in my heart I've abandoned them again
I've left them why I've gone to prison
yeah I mean any time away from that it
comes to me or when they said [ __ ] you
did a great job Joseph you're [ __ ]
married to this [ __ ] thing I don't
know how to [ __ ] like respond I'm I
say thank you very much but inside I
just crying I say God don't let me [ __ ]
this up all right I didn't make me cry
right no I don't want to right now
that's what matter any in any for me
like I could watch all right someone
braked her heart you know in a love
movie and everybody's crying because
they broke his heart and I'm the limb
was not crying
cuz I don't know was that like you have
your heart broken like that but when I
see a father-and-son moment I'm bawling
no puppy
because dad died they were [ __ ] River
Austin Powers
yes when the one with dr. evil yeah yeah
yeah gogo member when his daddy's right
there they're talking Danny she was
right in his [ __ ] now he goes up he
got he got him those laser sharks doctor
break you down I was sitting in [ __ ]
prison
there's 2002 and I watched John Q and I
[ __ ] bald from the beginning I know
what that little boy just wants to be
like that his his favorite [ __ ] a
bodybuilder and just I was like dude
Jenna I thought Denzel should have won a
[ __ ] owe the world on dude he take
that's me it nothing happening to my
babies cuz I always and I promised
myself I would never do to my children
the way that I was done
yeah I had already done that cycle I
going to prison but I made that
conscious decision I would never come
back and that's the path that I've been
on now you know like I pushed change as
possible like I hash take on me hash tag
King cuz I hash tag the [ __ ] about out
of that but that's change is possible
for any of their brothers [ __ ] weight
loss or it's [ __ ] stopped in droves
or stopped gang banging or a different
job but you know change is possible for
anybody and Mike my life is dedicated
now just to give him back because I can
never make enough in a man's for the
[ __ ] that I've done and the pain that
I've caused people you know that's what
I feel sometimes to men like you know
like my hat my my grand success is see
people happy by watching me like they
see me go you know what that fat ass
fool could do it I could do it and I get
that bro like when I was I was in a
commercial a Spanish one
I was prodded like to spokesmen for a
Honda Fit yeah you know and I had just
won like Last Comic Standing but I was I
was like dirty like three years ago but
that just watching me and my character
on a commercial I see a lot of myself
bro he asked me ho ho come on and I said
let me see on how'd you get in
television
I just want to apply like everybody I
don't they don't make ya thought the
people that saw me and motorway rings ya
know you inspire like in their 40s in
that turn abroad not too late bro never
too late never too late having pictures
of acting class and hanging around with
people who are doing it already
dude it was what when I seen you you
know that the last last comment standing
when you when you were moving probably
we didn't even know each other and I was
so [ __ ] like I I could cry for you I
was so [ __ ] happy because the
connection we had was homeboy industries
import rights and I'm not from Bull
heisman for San Diego but it's so much
love and respect for father Greg and
what he's done for me like I'm a very
loyal [ __ ] like it was for the
hood yeah like that's how I am now with
life and trying to give back you know
what I'm saying and that's I always felt
the connection with you that's why when
I got my inbox you were like yeah man I
want to come to the [ __ ] up I was like
what the [ __ ] I couldn't be more
gracious
for reals man like whenever the last
cover Stanley in 2010 like they were
asking all the comedian what we do that
money if you win I'm buy a house I'm a
pop car I'm gonna pay my bills me and
brought I don't know what to do with
that money cuz you know I'm like you bro
and everybody listening out there you
could relate to this when all your money
or they were waiting for drugs you don't
know what to buy you don't know it's bad
you don't know what to buy it like it 12
it's like you're 12 years old again yeah
okay I won't but I'm a bigger and I ask
you right now so I just need a big an
ice cream so I said I was gonna donate
some of the money to a homeboy industry
because they had my back
you know what's so great about that when
I told him that they put him there put
homeboy and you see on NBC and they were
going through money troubles could be
Android we don't go through money
troubles before I want Camila legal we
did a one-nighter and down to my lake
and we gave all the money to homeboy
industry within the lab bro but it was
like a it was 2500 2500 cash I don't
know where bro yeah and you okay me like
a that's a month
paying for a part-timer not to be in the
hood game bro that's [ __ ] I love the
whole life nobody call them no
newspapers we didn't tell nobody it was
just
ourselves and then we didn't invite
father Greg and then that so the next
day so I'm Lisa took the check give it
to him [ __ ] you guys then when I was
beautiful and then when I won they saw
father Greg's being and then the people
who actually donate money remember that
oh I forgot snow rate this year so I
start doing any more money coming and we
donate money we distill donate every
year now yeah yeah so that's interesting
that I don't want to keep yes too long
we got it go but you you said when like
some people get intimidated right on the
set if they haven't run into people who
look like you or maybe some of the
people in the mind and you say well I'm
I'm not that kind of person or I used to
be you know I'm not anymore so when you
look back on your on your childhood or
when you were gang banging and stuff do
you feel like you still wear that you're
this person inside that person back in
the day like because you still had
thoughts and feelings like maybe this
isn't right or maybe there's a better
life out there for me did you did you
have those ideas and those hopes and
dreams or was it just numbness and kind
of a cloud over you during that time
there was definitely a cloud there was
numbness at times but I always I always
had them my grandma used to you know and
my mother she'd been strung out sick as
it sounds she would tell me they loved
me my father would tell me he loved me
he be making trances you know I mean
like I'd be watching for the e-license
play back then for the Undercovers and I
was little on a skateboard running
through the Golden Hills so I knew when
they were coming to raid the pad but I
always knew in my heart cuz I was hit by
a car twice before I was four so they
would always tell me you were [ __ ]
you're here for a reason I whatever
[ __ ] I was here for a reason we
wouldn't be in the hood but a part of my
heart always knew I would be something I
always didn't know what and I swear on
God dude that gave me it kept me like
alive like I should have went insane
when I faced I was one of the first
hundred on the 186 22 a 22 B which is
the gang enhancement law in 97 and they
I was a two-striker then it was doubled
up 44 years 88 Sal I've lost face for
attempted murder I didn't commit but
they don't give a [ __ ] because you're
guilty by association
yeah so after two years of fighting in
the county jail I ended up getting eight
year
with 85% and I say all that to say there
when you're fighting life in prison
people don't realize talk about mental
health you know that [ __ ] you're scared
you don't have a [ __ ] there's no end
result you're in limbo and then you got
the politics and the [ __ ] that's inside
there that you have to you know I'm
saying jump when it jumps right and I
represented that time at that time so
it's I never lost hope of getting out
because I really wanted to be successful
but I didn't know what success was I
wanted happiness but I knew I didn't
know what it really was I just knew it
wasn't the [ __ ] that I was living in but
I didn't have enough [ __ ] balls that
is crazy stand up I found balls to stand
up when my son was born when my son was
born I was already faced in life but
when my son was born that's when I said
to myself I'm stepping away and I
stepped away from the home he's and a
lot of them got mad but I don't give a
[ __ ] because my own father burn a manor
and that's all I want to be as a father
and somebody that gives back to this
world and because it makes it is better
as I possibly can because I've [ __ ] it
up I moan enough you know I mean and man
being a father just gives me life man I
wake up every day and first thing I do
is talk to my babies you don't I'm
saying that's that's what makes me man
yeah I mean when I want to say [ __ ]
people get me mad I think about my kids
or I pulled at the picture of my kids
you know like this I got to bring my
daughter my youngest daughter the Toy
Story 4 you know she dressed up his
[ __ ] Jesse my son together like this
is the things that I'm able to instill
these these visions and plant these
seeds like her their mother's beautiful
and great as well and she never left
them she [ __ ] stood she was my
homegirl Flocka yeah she stood to the
plate now she's an optician she's the
best mother I know I was the one who
abandoned her went to prison and came
back and had to make my amends and be
the man that I am now and I'm still
[ __ ] it up but I don't give up and it
is one day at a time and it is beautiful
because you yeah I'm sure you looked you
knew other guys that you were hanging
out with back then and they're not oh
not all cholos are the same you know
they've got dynamics you've got
different personalities you've got
different experiences and knowledge so
I'm sure you ran into others who you
were like that guy couldn't make it if
he just wasn't here oh this guy could do
XY and Z or this dumb bike they all have
like you loved there's Alex you escaped
in movies and these other people escape
maybe
somebody like to read but that's not
something that you do and our draw no
there's a lot I mean like recently on
the minds that been my home but grumpy
flow monster doodle says my well yeah I
grew up with him another guy out there
said oh noes for me San Diego they got a
they just started a program youth
empowerment and these dudes were
somebody you know I mean they put a lot
of work in the game did a lot of time
and now they're giving back to their
communities and I'm trying to reconnect
with them and bring them into Hollywood
cuz they're always asking me can I get
me on the same thing well here let's go
to central casting let's put you on and
then you do the rest like you have to do
some of it I can lead you to the water
but I can't make you drink it bro you
don't I'm saying but like you said you
inspire others they want it they
probably wanted to buy that [ __ ] car
you were selling I mean not not just be
on TV well that's that's a beautiful
thing but that's humbling to know the
power that you have by changing your
life for the better when the others in
the same predicament that you grew up
with maybe they want that and then they
see that [ __ ] hope that's what life's
about for me right now yeah man was so
full Johnny Rock your man what you got
tonight I'm at mayor's hot dogs in
Pasadena eight-hour passive and Corpus
Christi Friday Saturday hell yeah yeah
October 16th we have a new show cracking
in Boyle Heights called lacunae that's
impressive
no it's English Oh English comedy show
I'll be hosting it right there so we'll
come out check my Instagram for details
social media wait you're at the
Paramount Boyle Heights a brand new one
yeah so we're gonna try to shoot the
Spanish special it's nice bro and Cher
and Sonny and Cher's to own it back in
the day - what up fool Lisa we're gonna
be at new projects coming up no new
projects coming up right now besides
season two man we got the rest of season
- last night was episode 4 so we got 5 6
7 8 9 10 watch her creeper baby listen
we're so full and you're in the best
podcast out there bro yes Mayans FX
right where's FX yeah 10 p.m. Tuesday
nights baby just through hell that todo
they go through Mexico yes we do [ __ ] as
we Spencer kills me bro like
today that's like well in the first one
you shot me the [ __ ] man he already
gave me a [ __ ] sex change cuz I don't
speak Spanish yeah then that that big
homie he went in he went to a Tony where
somebody's porch yeah yeah yeah that's
that's Gilly that's the one that got me
out of the [ __ ] car he's an ex-cop
yeah he's an ex [ __ ] arranger and [ __ ]
he s Jews Gilley was at the parade too
Gilley was slippery right I'm not sure
if he was there I know that um Richard
covered always there Emilio was there so
big hang closer hang clothes at the
Frankie Delgado that's what that was
Gilly yeah nothing to see me Lewis I
mean though may not have been there you
know what cuz Emilio's not riding right
now that's he's he's uh he's just
chillin what's up for what's your
Instagram Joe Rockhead Johnny ro q ue
Johnny Instagram all right man thank you
very much man thank you very much